legendary actor paul cervino has died he
was 83 years old you know hard work is
good in itself if you like what you're
doing
et's learned that paul died monday
morning his wife dede by his side the
two married in 2014. i saw her and i
said that's for me that's all there is
to it the actor's death follows several
health issues over the past few years
along with dede paul is survived by his
five grandchildren and three adult
children including actress mira sorvino
i think you've got a really proud dad
over there i do meera mourned her father
on twitter writing a life of love and
joy and wisdom with him is over he was
the most wonderful father i love him so
much i'm sending you love in the stars
dad as you ascend the picture i just
told you
paul got his acting start on broadway
but later became one of hollywood's most
recognizable stars
you'll triple my price showing up in
some iconic movies and you you got to
take it easy i think i am really good in
it and i think it is a great movie
and something that people will talk
about for years and years to come and
i'm very proud to have been a part of it
perhaps my best experience as an actor
in my entire career
for fans of goodfellas paul's death
tragically marks a second major loss
this year following ray liotta's death
in may when i'm telling ray in the
backyard don't make a jerk out of me
that means anybody all right yeah yeah
and i smacked him
i got his attention yeah that wasn't in
the script it wasn't in the snow so at
the end of it i said ray i'm awfully
sorry he said no paul was great because
he's 100 actor mira later took up the
family business she won the oscar for
best actress in 1996 for mighty
aphrodite in her acceptance speech mira
thanked her father for teaching her
everything she knows about acting making
paul tear up on live tv so i was right
in front of him and i was pretty much
speaking to him half the time did you
expect that he would break down like
that
yeah we're that kind of family
we cry a lot
i cry a lot he cries a lot we come by it
naturally paul shared his emotional
reaction with e.t after the ceremony and
as soon as they said her name
the spirit of my father engulfed my body
and the neapolitan blood can went rising
to the top innervating or rather
energizing my vocal chords and there i
was with
she won
and things she said i'll remember as
long as i left
you